in trigonometry and then again like
yesterday in quadratics we've done this
thing we've compared the same object in
the first case a wavefunction and in the
second case a quadratic equation
quadratic expression I should say and
we've looked at the same object from two
different angles we've looked at the
same object from two different angles
mathematicians are really big on this
because mathematics allows us to model
lots of different kinds of objects in
the same kind of underlying way so you
can look at different objects as seen
they're the same DNA and the same
patterns of behavior make sense
underneath all of them locus is a whole
topic devoted to this idea because we've
been thinking about shapes since forever
like since like your new one or
something like that even in kindy and yo
you're looking at triangles and hexagons
and moving things around we think about
shapes we go from shapes to the idea of
thinking about shapes in a logical way
and reasoning through them right it's
one of the first places and last places
that we think about deduction in a very
formal way and we call that we give it a
fancy name and we say oh we're now doing
geometry right we don't just look at the
shapes and say oh this is interesting we
actually look at them and we observe
properties and we measure them that's
what metree means and we are trying to
understand these things more deeply but
then around you seven actually we start
to realize that geometry can be sort of
supercharged if you try and quantify
where everything is not just like this
length is this and this angle is that
but where is every individual component
that makes it up so we give everything
coordinates and we say hey you cannot
just know that this side is going to be
this long and this angle is this big but
you can say this point is exactly here
this line goes exactly at that angle at
that gradient and so this kind of took
this and made it a lot more detail okay
now what we're doing is we're looking at
all of these ideas sort of together in a
harmonious away as we can very familiar
familiar kinds of shape but looked at
through a different lens I'm gonna ask
us to do some drawings now and the
drawings are each going to represent the
things that we did up on the serpentine
wall we did four things didn't we I
think the first one was based on a
central point and then you positioned
yourself do you remember okay the second
one was based on I mean there was the
two trees well they're not the two trees
and then you position yourselves the
third one was between the line and me
and then the last one was back to the
two trees but we did something different
you remember that I'm gonna give you
that five minutes now if you've got more
than one color that will be helpful
because there was always features that
you shaped yourselves around and then
there was you guys right and you
position yourselves in different spots
I'm gonna give you three or four minutes
to take those four scenarios and draw
them as best as you can and then I'll
put mine up on the board as well off you
go so let's go back to the beginning and
let's think about the easiest one right
that's why I started with it if you take
a central point and you define you say I
want everyone else to position
themselves so they're the same distance
from that central point then very
quickly and almost without even moving
you can see that the shape you form if
you're not just had a bunch of points
but if you had every point the shape you
would fall of course is a circle so we
could actually join up this should be
actually a bit higher you could join up
all of the points like so and you'd say
oh I know what this is it's a circle and
this is the center right so a familiar
shape but just sort of viewed at a sort
of weird different angle different
perspective okay and then we said okay
here are two other fixed points rather
than just one and I want you to make
sure you're the same distance from each
so you can see we started to trace out
this and you had to do a little bit of
measurement it wasn't too difficult to
because number one there was the easy
spot right here in the middle right but
other spots were not too difficult
either because you could always buy I
say yeah I can see on the same distance
from there to there these two are equal
and these two are equal but they're
clearly not equal to each other does
that make sense you can keep on going
you know you can go further and further
away and you can still sort of see
what's got see what's going on by eye if
you join up all of those such points
then what you create is this straight
line but I want to point out it's not
just any straight line it's related to
these two trees in a very particular
geometric way we're trying to understand
geometry through this different kind of
lens I will come back to specifically
what kind of geometry that is in a
minute I just want you to think about it
okay
then we started to look at some harder
ones ones that you are less familiar
with I said hey can you position
yourself the same distance from me as
from the line and we had to comment on
the fact that when you're talking about
the distance to a line you don't just
mean any distance to any point on the
line you mean the the perpendicular
distance which is the shortest right so
as usual are the person who could move
the quickest which I think maybe was
Jake the person who moved the quickest
buy the easiest spot which is the one
that is in the middle of those two right
so if that's the midpoint but then you
had to look around and see other points
and excuse me when you've got your
diagram just like here I want you to
measure some of these on there for me
for instance you've got this guy here
that distance has to match up to this
distance this was the distance I asked
Morgan to walk if you recall right I
said take a person any person walk to me
find what that is and then walk to the
line but you've got a world walk
perpendicular right so in both of these
cases there's a right angle what we want
is for these to be equal to each other
and the
to be equal to each other but as before
not necessarily
in fact definitely not equal to each
other it gets a bit harder the further
you go away the harder it is to measure
what's going on but you still can right
so again these are equal to each other
even though they're not equal to the
rest now because you are doing your best
to find nice accurate spots you didn't
go all that far I forced you to go
further on this last one we'll come to
in a minute but if you have a look at
the shape that you traced it out
you ought to somewhat recognize that
it's true part of that if you hide it
part of it does look like a semicircle
but it's not going to be a semicircle in
the end we'll talk about why exactly you
can know that in a minute okay last one
to remember what was the rule that I
gave you with this one what did I ask
you to do twice as far from one tree as
you were from the other okay so again
there's one spot there's the cheap spot
which is the easiest to find which is if
you're directly between the two trees if
you're on this imaginary interval let's
say you want to be twice as far from two
as you are from one so you want any
closer to one okay the spot that you
would want would be somewhere around
here I guess can you think back track
back through the ways that we've been
looking at this idea in the past
particularly this year under here we
have a way to actually specifically find
within a coordinate geometry scheme
where that point is what did we call it
does it all remember we call it ratio
division right that's the point which
divides an interval into a given ratio
in this case it would be 1 to 2 does
that make sense
so I could say 1 to 2 now this becomes a
little harder to visualize and that's
what we experienced when we were out
there right I want you to notice that we
had people and I think it was driven
Jake right yeah yep excuse me we had
driven Jake and they were not like most
people were between the trees in some
way in sort of like in this middle strip
but
on the outside where were they on which
side were they remember we want you to
be further away from tree - as you are
from tree one so that means you clearly
have to be on this side yeah if you're
anywhere on this side you're closer
there - then one so we actually were on
this side and if you think again
carefully where they had to position
themselves was exactly here as if they
were a third tree does that make sense
as if they were in a row can you see why
because have a look I'm gonna need
another color for this can you see that
this distance here has to be half this
distance here does that make sense it's
the same ratio right one two - okay now
where would the rest of you where would
the rest of you on your piece of paper
now you have the advantage of the fact
that you can rule things you can measure
things and what have you you did notice
there was a bit of an arc sort of around
here forming this kind of shape I think
shown you was somewhere around here
weren't you that's what I think you sort
of position yourself around here okay
now I'm gonna stop there I'm going to
let this hang and let you think about
what is going on here we're going to
find out we're going to do the number
crunching within this topic to show you
how to find out exactly what this shape
is but I'm just going to I'm gonna get
Game of Thrones on your wait for the
last you know few episodes to actually
make sure you find out what that is so
I'm not gonna I don't want you to say it
out loud if you think you know what that
is but I've given you enough points that
you could make a decent guess okay now
before we get down to the nitty-gritty
details of the mechanics of how this
works how do we find out what actually
these things are not just by eye but
with you know algebra and stuff like
that which is a very powerful tool we
introduced that gets you accuracy not
just a vague sense okay remember I said
to you hey this is not just any line
it's a specific line it's related
actually in a similar way to this did
you notice this line here is
perpendicular has to be perpendicular
right in addition to that it bisects
that
between the trees okay so this light
here is not just a straight line it is
the perpendicular what's the name of the
line which cut something in half
bisector of the intervals interval
between the two trees right this guy up
here is a parabola I've drawn it as such
and we're going to prove that it's the
case this last one let's just leave that
home for a little bit okay